just let me say a few the key messages I
mean other people think that you still
have to wait for new brakes with
technology and I don't think that's the
case we have the existing technologies
but they have to break through and that
doesn't come by itself and
unconventional erica was in big surprise
to everyone say in the last decade but
the first pioneers were already out
there trying to develop the technology
in the 80s so it takes a few decades
about three decades for new technology
to really come through and that's a very
normal time span in the energy in this
industry to actually have new
technologies coming on stream to about
one percent market share when it
actually becomes competitive with
existing incumbents so bear the mind
three decades before it becomes
competitive another three decades before
it actually reaches a notch at natural
market share so it's a really internet
intergenerational game then the other
aspect is something about efficiency a
lot of policy is based on efficiency
that we're going to improve slightly
gayer something built in around fifteen
percent of next 25 years but efficiency
doesn't come by itself it has his own
dilemmas policy dilemmas because you
know who's going to pay for it because
if an end consumers not to have the
expectation that end consumer price will
continuously rise why would invest now
upfront a lot of money to invest in
efficiency while government's normally
like to say that energy should be more
affordable and come cheaper every day
and here's kind of India kata me too to
breach another critical technology which
we have to really come to grips with
soon is carbon capture and sequestration
CCS read to decarbonize the power system
I'm afraid if you want a lower carbon
system you can't do without a
technological fix called carbon capture
and sequestration then my second key
point is actually that gas will be a
backbone of sustainable energy systems
of the future why do I say that well
guess its abundant and affordable etc
but if you want to have more and more
renewables intermittent renewables in
your system you need a kind of backbone
flexible backup source which can
actually take up the flexibility very
cost efficiently now we have done a lot
of scenario exercises and every time I
can see that actually gas is a very good
cost-effective way to actually deal with
it in the mitten see but also we see
some kind of natural saturation points
in certain sectors off renewables so
when people say hundred percent
renewables for everything is possible I
doubt it and certainly not in the next
20 years so gas will be really important
in the future and then after the third
main point is actually that is urgent
policy action required people think they
have time because 2050s long way eighty
percent then reduction seems to be still
doable but this kind of momentum you
have to build up now and we see actually
a lack of policy development certainly
in a meaningful co2 price because that's
the best way of actually steering
consumers behavior in doing more
energy-efficient things or actually pay
for new low carbon technologies like CCS
and also something what is quite often
forgotten is market structures here a
lot of debate about electricity market
and you know we want to have mandated
renewables in because it's too costly to
the free market way so you get that and
then it's aof intermittency how to solve
that oh we need capacity payments for
generators to have capacity standby
that's great so the generators get a
kind of more market-based conversations
you could argue but that really pushes
the flexibility requirement down the
supply chains to the volume providers
the guest providers in this case of coal
providers cause easier for heap and you
ever built carrier but guess comes long
distances in gas pipelines of her LNG's
and when there is no security of demand
because you have no clue how much you
going to sell what the price is going to
be why should Russia develop a field
10,000 kilometers away from us well he
doesn't have a long term contract to
finances and that there's another
security and supply element so I would
say is yes you need market reform but
also the commercial aspects of market
reform needs to be taken much more
consideration an integrated way between
electricity and gas etc and accumbens
and then my last point is really that
the key uncertainties are there and I
meant intervention gases a very good
example right will it really be
replicable elsewhere in the world it's
the success of North America is that
going to happen in China and South
America maybe in more modest form here
that's not very certain look at the
policy debaters a public debate about
fracking people don't really sure right
and why should we do that but if
unconventional gas is successful it
really doubles the previous thought
resource base of gas and then it really
makes it a real game change you can
really go for different type of energy
systems in a sense that you can early
gains replace coal by gas but su build
and big infrastructure system on gas
also you start opening up options for
the future I will call it say you have
room to maneuver in 2020 2030 s because
you have a gas infrastructure which is
also easily as little extra cost they
make suitable for hydrogen gas or liquid
hydrogen so actually make aren't you
lucky because you have an infrastructure
you can piggyback on if you do in other
routes then you don't have the
infrastructure and then it becomes very
expensive to introduce hydrogen why do I
mention hydrogen because renewables yes
it's a good idea to decarbonize but it
needs storage needs some way of
exploring these electrons in your useful
form and also it needs a medium to
actually be useful in other sectors than
electricity like science of
transportation so maybe in 10 year 20
years time when the hydrogen technology
has really evolved very cost effectively
and you have liquid hydrogen car liquid
hydrogen you can transport and tankers
it really become complementary of such
gas system and it gives you much more
flexibility in the future then are a few
key uncertainties as well and i'll just
say China most people think ball joint
is far away what is do with us our gas
position well China's decision on policy
on the energy mix is very
determining how much gas will be
available in the rest of the world if
China feels comfortable saying four
times of five times their present and
gas consumption by 2030 then the market
will be as big as the e use market as
today and 600 BC M is a lot of gas
coming from the market yes they will
have some domestics a supply but more so
more the more that own uncle venture gas
becomes successful in you in China the
more infrastructure they're going to
build so the more guest penetration you
have in China so the more comfortable
they are to import a lot of gas P&G and
guess what who competes against that
it's the EU foremost and I'm almost
finished and the last point I want to
make is acceptability really we talk
about all those native new technologies
but it's very much new technologies are
hard to have accepted by the public if
it's uncle venture gas is the fracking
debate if its carbon capture storages
yes great but not under my my house
although people are very happy with
producing gas under the house for many
years but they're not sure about this
YouTube position so social acceptability
is a real issue which you have to deal
with and as a shell right we are more
and more now convinced that we have to
engage communities for instance very
upfront to to be forward to make it an
acceptable and maybe I should stop here
then if you want to be in time that
would be very noble of you good good
thank you thank you very much
I have a natural agitation of a radio
presenter I think every 30 seconds is a
crime against humanity but it does it
allows us to have a bit more discussion
later but we're going to have a brief
discussion now about some of the
subjects that are arising from that very
interesting presentation do we have some
questions anybody to get us going with
questions and could you of course please
identify yourself when you ask your
question good evening my name is Chameli
botella and I'm from Paris France as
humanity and from accent I've known him
for a number of years and they happy
just to make a first comment which is a
very good icing summary of what is known
and what is also unknown and I think
that there are at least two points with
which are alien known the first one is I
would say the avid sorry the
availability of carbon capture and
sequestration and you put it clearly but
I just want to insist another point
which seems to me very important is
whether or not shale gas will appear in
other regions of the world I know that
she'll as bet honors as a shell gas in
China but I think in China's are
enormous problem they are problem of
access our problem of water they are
problem of Georgie because the shale gas
is cheap let's stop there because you've
actually made two very nice pointed
questions at end of one view of your own
so if you remind I would just like to
take an answer to yes let me pick up the
point of how certainly is this uncle
venture gas revolutions elsewhere in the
world in North America North America
seems to be on the roads but still
people have to realize that the success
are what are called sweet spots
geological sweet spot so it's a big area
but if by random drilling over
all this 30 years they found certain
areas but actually it is really
profitable to do it but Uncle Vinci gas
wells are not so prolific as normal as
well so you have to drill an awful lot
of them and you have to do much more
technology to that but it seems that
North America has cracked up and people
very confident that certainly North
America in a gas supplied amount is more
or less self balancing or even can start
and exporting LNG the second point is
how how success was in confidential gas
in the rest of the world and I would say
that's anyone's guess maybe we are
geologically but still a lot of wells
have to be drilled people have to have
confidence that actually they can't find
sweet spots there's a lot of societal
debate still and therefore our new
scenarios which are going to publish in
beginning next year one of the critical
in certain says we call the scenarios is
is that gasps there or isn't that gas
there but really because that's almost
bought bipolar if it's there you have an
enormous opportunity to change your
energy system but if it's there it'll be
fairly regional simpy uncertainty still
any more questions out there oh yes
quite a lot of hands I'll take a couple
of together i'd like to take gentlemen
the second row in the lady of the yellow
top jacket three thank you yes i'm paul
eakins from University College London
Institute sustainable resources think of
your talk also UK Energy Research Center
two very quick questions based on
statements that were made the first is
by the chair that gas was a relatively
low option compared with coal well that
of course is true in those countries
where it would substitute for coal but
the UK is not one of those and it is
often presented as a substitute for coal
in the UK but we won't have coal in the
UK to any extent beyond 2020 and the
second which you said when which is that
it will deal with intermittency it will
indeed and will be crucial to deal with
intermittency but only at very low
levels of use and at the moment the
market would not subsidized or the
market would not bear investment in gas
fired power stations in that very low
level of use so my questions to you are
is the extensive use of unabated gas
compatible with the UK's car
reduction targets in 2050 and if not as
I suspect should we wait for any new
dash for gas until the technical and
commercial feasibility of gas CCS has
been proved hold that thought it was
just a second why we take the ladies
questioningly 12 fifth row in the yellow
jacket you passed along as quickly as
you can thank you and thank you I'm
Charlotte Morton from the anaerobic
digestion and buying gas association
which potentially reveals my question it
was a very interesting presentation and
i agree with lot of the issues i'm just
surprised that in talking about gas
there has been no mention of renewable
gas which therefore helps address the co
tuitions them issues by gas can generate
about ten percent of the UK's domestic
gas demand so why wouldn't we be looking
at it and it can be scaled up very fast
and very cheaply you have those in your
mind yeah two parts and then the second
place so I agree with that also the
Netherlands are looking at biogas we
have a lot of animals waste etc we can
use we that is estimated can be eight
percent of the total gas demand in
certain sectors so it's significant and
it's being developed and actually you
can see actually be developed not
because of code from policy big but
because of farmers and then the
greenhouse growers actually see there's
a good cost effective way to reduce the
energy bill so it's actually it's going
on another element actually in this
greenhouse gas business and agriculture
is such a geothermal warmth right well
actually directly take it from the
ground or actually use solar boringness
so this integrated loop systems in
certain areas is really taking off and
then I come back to Paul's point as yes
biogas is very important of commercial
biomass if it's in our terms and we
assume that there will be quite a
significant amount of biogas available
which goes into gas-fired power stations
and also in our outlook we assume that
CCS is going to be developed on all new
power stations post-2020 in your
honestly otherwise you don't go there
now having said that I mean said early
gainsay with replaces a little bit of
coal left in Indian UK plus the downturn
in economic activity plus the efficiency
drive which supposed to happen probably
the UK could have something like butts
in fifteen to twenty percent carbon
reduction compared to nineteen ninety by
in 2020 but thereafter becomes very
difficult and then it becomes sure what
kind of poles do you take if it is
unabated then you will get stuck to that
that you can't learn further so you must
have CCS and that's what we assume in
our modeling but then we still get stuck
around 45 at best forty five percent for
2050 and if it's a kind of business as
usual scenario so you don't have much
polish support for ccs you probably will
stick to about you go down you go back
up to only fifteen percent abatement so
yes without guests without CCS in long
term is not the the solution for a lower
carbon system it has to come combined
and that's why our company is actually
is willing to invest a lot in their
technology and demonstrate it can be
done commercially and cost-effectively
thank you very much then as a
particularly like you did you want to
continue I mean if you if you feel that
you've covered it but if there's
anything else you want to say very
briefly we'll just don't think I'm yes
I'm fine well in that case you are
retired oh thanks oh
you